We just learned a whole bunch of
stuff about arrow functions, and
really the only way to make it
sink in now is to do some
practice. I've got two exercise
lined up for you and how this is
going to work is I'm going to
explain it and then you go off
and do it. Then you come back
and continue this video and I'm
going to show you how I would
have solved and to sort of
compare your answers. There's
obviously going to be way more
than one possible answer so if
it works for you that's probably
a pretty good solution. This is
the actual problem that I had --
I'm in the exercise folder for
the arrow functions here -- once
where I actually wanted to sum
up a YouTube series and say it
was this many hours, but I
didn't know like a nice way to
do that. However, YouTube would
list all of my videos here and
they would have a data attribute
of data-time equals 5 minutes
and 17 seconds, 7 minutes and 24
seconds. What I realized that
you could do is you could select
all of them, pop out the data
time, parse the minutes and
seconds into seconds, add them
all up, and you're off and ready
to go. You could do this in one
big reduce function, but since I
want you to get a practice with
working with arrow functions, so
I have to sort of step through
where you can use filter(), map(),
map(), and reduce to get the
total, and that's going to
really help us. Go ahead and do
that one. I'll show you exercise
two as well. This is a little
bit easier, we've got an array
of numbers here, and use the
filter method and an arrow
function to create an array of
numbers that are greater than 70,
pretty straightforward, but it
should just be a nice quick one-
liner for you. Good luck with
that and I will see you back in
a couple of minutes. Hopefully,
you had a good time with that
let's go through it together.
The first one we'll select all
the listed times on the page and
convert it to an array. Select
all of them, so const items,
equals, we'll use document.
querySelector() all here, and
we're going to select them. How
should we select them? There's
no class or ID or anything on
there, the one thing that it
does have in common is that it
has a data-time attribute. I'm
going to use an attribute
selector, just square brackets
anything with a data-time set on
it, I want to select it.
Actually I'm running in Chrome
Canary and probably by the time
you watch this it's going to be
available in standard Chrome and
all your other browsers, but in
some of the older browsers these
items if I console.log it, this
is, it looks like an array but
what is it? It's a NodeList and
NodeList doesn't have methods
like map() and filter() and all
of the things that we're using,
so it's not a true array, it is
just a NodeList. While this is
changing, not all browsers
support all of the methods that
we want to use, so in order to
convert it to a true array we
can just wrap the entire thing
in array.from or any of the
other favorite convert to arrays
things there and that is going
to make it a true array logic.
Give it a refresh, open it up.
You see now the prototype is an
array not a NodeList, but we
still have all the items there.
Now we have these items variable
here and let's move through all
of the ones. The first one is
filter() only for the items that
contain the word flexboxes.
Maybe I have some jumbled videos
in here that I don't want to add
up. The ones that have redux on
them and my selector wasn't
smart enough to look for
anything, the class or redux, as
we didn't have the data in that
situation. We'll say const
filtered = items.filter and we
can use an arrow function here
where we are only going to
return it if the items, text
content includes -- text content
is  case -- the
word flexbox, so that should, we
take this filtered variable.
Let's go all the way to the
bottom here in console.log()
filter(), because we're just
going to be changing this
filtered variable as we go. We
had 20, now we've got 15, good.
We've got our 15 items that I've
filtered down. What I'm going
to do is I'm also going to just
put this on its own line,
because we're going to be
chaining this filter(), map(),
map(), and reduce() functions on
each other, so I just like to
have them each on their own line.
The next step is map down to a
list of time strings. This is
just a list of elements. We
don't need the entire element.
We just need that one piece of
data which is the data-time
attribute. How do we do that?
Map() will take in a list of
things and convert it into a
list of other things. We want to
take in the item and we want to
return the item.dataset.time.
Why? Because that's going to
give us data-time, so now I
think if we refresh we should
now see an array. Error on 40
item.days.time, I got it,
semicolon, I shouldn't have
stopped my line there, because
we're chaining these line over
lines, so I shouldn't have that
semicolon there. Now, I've got
an array of still 15 items, but
now we have a string of the time
which is the problem in our next
one which is map() to an array
of seconds. We can use map()
again and let's just say we'll
call it timecode. We can't just
use an implicit return here like
we've done here. We don't have
curly brackets, we don't have
the return keyword, because
we're just doing one quick thing.
Over here we need to use a full
block because we are going to do
a couple of things here. First
of all we need to separate the
string into minutes and seconds.
I'm going to make a variable
called parts, and that is going
to be time code.split, and we're
going to split it on the colon.
I think if we just said console.
log the parts...Let's see what
we got here, timecode, timecode
again, make sure we got your
case correct.
We're getting an array now of
two parts. First piece is going
to be the full number of minutes,
the second piece is going to be
the full number of seconds.
This is still a string and you
know that we can't do math with
a string, so we can actually
just work on this, this .split
returns an array. Why don't we
just map that array immediately
and take that part and return
parse float of that part. What
that's going to do is it's going
to take in string of 8 and
return number 8. It's going to
take in string 22, return number
22. Now if you refresh, lately
they just turned blue and that
means that they are true numbers
and no longer strings. That was
a little arrow function inside
of an arrow function here,
that's the beauty of this arrow
function is you can just do
quick little things like that on
a single line without having to
really worry about setting up an
entire function for us. That's
good. I'm going to move this
console.log here. We've got an
array of minutes and seconds and
we need to just return from this
map(). We need to return the
parts zero, the first thing,
times 60, is we want to return
second in total. Plus we just
want to return the number of
seconds, so parts of 60 plus
parts one. Now our time code
should be -- we've got an array
of just seconds, seconds,
seconds, seconds, seconds. Final
thing we need to do is reduce to
get the actual total here.
Reduce takes two arguments,
first one is going to be our
function which will give us the
running total and the actual
seconds number. Then it also --
that's the function here, and
I'll leave that right there --
takes a number to start with.
Even though we don't technically
need that in this case let's
keep it there just so we know
that we're starting with zero.
We go on, and then from our
arrow function we are going to
just return the running total
plus the seconds for this
current one. I'll give that a
save, 6,132 seconds that's where
we are at. I probably would have
another function that would take
in the seconds and then convert
that to hours, minutes, and
seconds and display it, but
that's a whole another exercise
on itself. That's really what
we wanted to do there as we just
did one thing. We took this huge
list of DOM elements converted
it all the way down, distilled
it all the way done just to a
number of seconds. That is the
first one, let's take a look at
the second one now. Exercise two,
should be a piece of cake for
you now. That's just one line of
code, so what we're going to say
is we're going to say const
large equals numbers.filter, and
we want to return the number if
it is larger than 70, if not
then we don't want to do
anything. We get the number and
we run a function where it says
number is greater than 70. If
the number is greater than 70
that will be true and therefore,
it will make it into the large
if not it won't make it. We got
there, good to go, one-liner.
I'm really happy with that.
Hopefully those exercises were
good for you. Let's keep going
with the rest of ES6.